for you is regarding a person who has a
wet dream during the day whilst he's
fasting is this an act which would
nullify the fast is it permitted for a
person to have a wet dream during the
day while she's fasting if a person has
a wet dream during the day while having
a fast maybe offers F Salah and he
sleeps and he has a w dream it is
involuntary a person has a w dream even
if ejaculates it's involuntary he's not
to be blamed for that in this case
because
unintentional surely it will not break
the fast and he can complete the Fast
and the thing that is advised to him is
that he should have a g a bath as soon
as possible so that he can offer the
Salah that's excellent I think that's
self-explanatory thank you for that
another question very much related to
the last one I feel um is a person
allowed to be in a state of sexual
impurity whilst they're fasting as far
as the question that can a person be in
a state of sexual
impurity that depends if as long as it
does not do any Haram act during the
fast for example it's mentioned in the
Hadith of wasallam in s Muslim volume
number two Hadith number 2453 it's
mentioned that um Salma M pleased with
her for the wife of the Prophet she says
that the prophet got up from his sleep
in a state of sexual defilement state of
sexual impurity while he was fasting and
he had a bath and he continued his
fast
further there's a similar message given
in s bukari volume number three in the
book of fasting Hadith number 1925 and
the Hadith is narrated Again by um Salma
pleased with her Anda pleased with her
too both are the wives of the prophet
and they said that the prophet used to
get up in the in the morning in a state
of sexual defilement because he had
intercourse with the wife not because of
a sexual
dream and he used to have a bath and he
never used to compensate the fast later
on this proves that being in the state
of junub sexual defilement or sexual
impurity does not nullify the fast even
if a person has a we dream in between
his fast is valid the only point to be
noted is that the person should have a
bath as soon as possible if he gets up
in the morning after Dawn breaks and if
he's in a state of sexual impurity
should have a bath immediately so that
he can offer the Salah of faj or if he
sleeps after F Salah and has a wet dream
and then become sexually impure so he
should have a bath at least before the Z
Salah so that he can offer the Z Salah
after having a Gul okay that I think
that sheds some light on that issue and
the same thing if a person is
menstrating if a lady if she's menr
and she finishes the Minal cycle just
before
fa and she delays a bath even after Dawn
is broken and she has a bath just before
the F Salah that's also valid